nobody trusts my sister less than I do
believe me but if we go to the capital
we'll go with two armies we'll go with
three dragons anyone touches you King's
Landing burns down to the foundation
stones and right now she's thinking
about to set a trap of course she is and
she's wondering what trap you're laying
for her no we laying any traps what's up
ladies and gentlemen welcome back for
another Game of Thrones Season eight
update video yesterday I released a
video with some new photos that were
taken in Dubrovnik which is where they
filmed their scenes for King's Landing
when I made that video there were some
photos of Jon Snow walking around the
city as they were filming a few scenes
for the eighth and final season at the
time Jon Snow was the only character
that was on set who I knew by name but
some more photos have came out that
reveal Cersei Lannister and the mountain
will be in some of these scenes with Jon
Snow as well I want to go over a few
things about these photos and I want to
clarify a few things that I said in the
last video I knew Cersei Lannister would
be involved because they are in King's
Landing but now we have photo evidence
of this and there are a few other things
I want to mention in this video also as
I stated yesterday some fans from
Dubrovnik have said they also spotted
Daenerys Targaryen but I have yet to see
any proof of that yet when I uploaded
the video some people left some comment
saying Sansa and bran were there too but
I haven't seen any photos of them either
so I can't confirm any of that right now
but if Shaun's and bran were to be there
that would be very interesting because
that could mean John and his entire
family had to flee the north most likely
due to the night king attacking and
burning Winterfell
but I don't want to speculate on that
too much until I see some more proof
also there was a photo of Jon Snow
walking around King's Landing and in
this specific photo there was a man
walking with him who was dressed in all
black I still can't make up this
person's face but his clothes can be a
good indicator as to who he might be at
first glance he appears to be a man of
the Nights Watch but when you zoom all
the way in his
also looks similar to what the tall E's
have worn if you look closely you can
see that it looks like fish scales
similar to what the blackfish in Edmure
Tully wore it would actually make more
sense if this was someone from River Run
because as we all know Suns a brain and
Orias mother was at Ollie and Ed Muir
should still be alive the last mention
of that mere thali was in the season 6
finale when Walder Frey said he put ed
near back into cells and this was right
before Arya killed Walder Frey I was
hoping Arya would free him while she was
there but they never showed her doing
that so I can only assume he is still
there somewhere but there is a very good
chance we will see the phrase again
which could mean ed mere gets released
and that could be a way that the tallest
could be brought back into the picture
there was a casting call for two young
actresses that are said to be playing
two of the Frey daughters Serra and
sarra Frey they could potentially
release him or Jamie could stop by the
twins before he gets to Winterfell and
Jamie could try and free ed Muir and
rally any troops that he can so he can
show up in Winterfell with a small force
of his own plus we should be seeing John
and saw ins that call all of their
banners to prepare for war so maybe
that's how John ends up with whoever
this mystery man is Dan and Dave were
also spotted on set and I know some of
you believe they may be the ones who are
directing this episode but I don't think
that's the case
dan and Dave are always seen on set
especially with this being the last
season and in one of these photos you
can see David Nutter standing right next
to them
I believe Dan and Dave are just there to
simply assist David D and D are
directing the season finale but I still
believe this will be episode four I made
my own little outline for how I think
things may play out based on what little
evidence we have so far if more photos
and reports come out I will make the
necessary adjustments since Jon and
Daenerys were heading to Winterfell in
the season 7 finale I think they will
show up in Winterfell in episode 1 John
will learn that the wall was destroyed
in the night King is heading their way
on a dragon they don't need to wait for
beric and torment to warn everyone
because bran was there when he was
watching it through the eyes of the
Ravens when Jon and Daenerys arrive in
episode 1 they will immediately start
preparing their forces for war John will
have all the dragonglass turned into
weapons and John and or so
we'll have to send ravens out to
everyone warning them at the night Kings
approach they will have to alert all of
their banners and tell them to come
north I think they're gonna need to stop
tonight King as soon as possible because
every day the night King is south of the
wall he could be potentially making his
army larger if they allow the night king
to destroy all of the north he could
possibly turn all of the north into
whites and they can't allow that to
happen in Episode two they will receive
reports of the night king destroying
karhold the last hearth and maybe even
the dreadfort the actors who play little
Ned umber and Elise Karstark were seen
in Belfast as they were preparing to
film so we know they will be in the next
season but not for long
John told them their castles will be the
first ones hit by the night King and
that's exactly what's gonna happen by
the end episode two all of the stark
banners should be in Winterfell and all
the weapons should be made in Winterfell
we'll have made weapons mounted around
the castle walls episode two could end
with the Starks receiving word that the
umbers and Karstarks were slaughtered I
think the night king will attack
Winterfell in Episode three in the
reason why I think that is because we
have already seen more than enough
evidence to prove Winterfell gets
attacked and burned since Winterfell
will be involved in a big battle this
will be directed by miguel support snick
who always directs the epic battle
scenes and he's directing episodes 3 & 5
Winterfell will get attacked and burned
midseason I don't know if they're gonna
be able to stop the night king in this
episode or not I would like to think
Winterfell will not fall this is where
winter had fallen before so maybe this
is where the new king of winter will
fall again as long as the stark is in
Winterfell they should be able to
prevail but maybe they don't maybe they
have to flee the north and that's why
John arrives in King's Landing in
episode 4 with David Nutter on set it
should be one of his episodes he's
directing an episode for makes the most
sense to me even if the Starks win and
defeat the night king in Episode three
John and Danny still need to come to
King's Landing and deal with Cersei
anyway they did offer her a truce during
the Great War but since she lied and
betrayed them they're gonna have even
more motivation to remove Cersei from
the capital John may try and speak with
Cersei alone and offer her some kind of
a
he may allow her to live if she is
willing to stand down and step away from
the Iron Throne that would explain why
John and Cersei are a meeting alone we
all know John's not a piece of [ __ ] so
he will probably try and show mercy
before Danny unleashes her dragons on
the city but we all know Cersei she
isn't about to just step down and allow
someone else to roll her city I wouldn't
be surprised if Cersei sets some kind of
a trap for Jon Snow and that will force
Daenerys to come in on her dragons and
burn everything like I said in the
previous videos they are building an
enormous set that is said to be King's
Landing this new structure looks almost
identical to the buildings in Dubrovnik
that stone is very similar in color they
have also performed some controlled fire
tests on this set because they are
planning to burn it down to the ground
at some point next season we will see
dragon fire kiss the buildings and
King's Landing but the question is are
they Danny's dragons or the night Kings
dragon that is still to be determined
but I can almost guarantee we will see
Danny's vision from the house of the
undying come true John will arrive in
Episode four to greet with Cersei but
something must go wrong the next episode
will be number five and that's directed
by Miguel so I can almost guarantee that
will be the final battle that we see
that is the episode right before the
finale and that's typically when Game of
Thrones films their biggest battles of
the season I think the timeline I made
up is fairly accurate but I am open for
suggestions I have no problem with
changing my opinions if the evidence
leans in another direction as I was
sitting here making this video another
piece of information just came out and
this is kind of crazy according to wiki
of Thrones one of their sources says the
Hound will be fighting some men from the
unsullied I don't even know what to
think of this their source says the
unsullied were seen surrounding the
Hound and they started to fight each
other it really doesn't even make any
sense they should all be fighting on the
same team unless these unsolved are
turned into whites which is very
possible other than that I really don't
know why this would happen could John
and Danny start opposing each other next
season over their claim I really don't
want to go down this road just yet
because there isn't any photo or video
evidence to prove this but I literally
just saw this get posted and I was
wait a minute what the hell I will put
all the links down in the description
that way you can read all of it for
yourself I also want to read a few
thoughts from some of my patreon
supporters then I will get out of here
shado says I looked at the photos and so
far I did not see Danny in them unless I
missed it the man with John snow doesn't
look like a night's watchman unless they
change their outfits some are saying
it's a guard because John snow doesn't
have long claw on his side but to put
one guard on John snow is just stupid
maybe he's not wearing his props in that
one shot the person next to John appears
to have on robes under his fur but it
could be dark leather too could this be
a faceless man or Oriya in a face of
some random person Jagan hugger maybe or
Euron's priest or someone from the
golden company wearing dark clothes but
I would think they would wear gold
Richard says I wonder if the leaks are
true the ones about them being locked up
and Jamie kill Cersei these are the
leaks I mentioned in yesterday's video
about Jon Snow being captured and locked
up by Cersei 42 answer says oh wow love
the ending of seeing the Iron Throne
destroyed maybe what John and Danny and
their child all together watching a
dragon burnin that would be so powerful
Marie Hill says there has to be some
meaning to the mad Kings burn them all
we have seen these scenes too many times
and also characters repeating the mad
Kings words just like winter is coming
it is embedded in our minds but why the
mad Kings Court is in King's Landing and
a wonder if Bloodraven or Bryan saw
white sand King's Landing there is a
theory that maybe bran or bloodraven was
sending the Mad King visions or dreams
or even whispering to him about the
whites coming and that's why he went mad
and was always saying burn them all it
only makes sense if the whites are lured
into King's Landing because of the
Wildfire which can only be found in
King's Landing this has also been
foreshadowed numerous times Tyrion at
the Battle of Blackwater Bay Jamie tells
Brienne Tyrion tells Daenerys and
Khaybar knows where it is
so perhaps John and Danny go to King's
Landing with Jaime to use the wildfire
against the whites and this is where we
see the dragon flying over King's
Landing that is very interesting Marie
and there may be something to that
I have heard that theory before and it's
not that bad
and with all the recent developments
coming out perhaps it does happen what
does everyone else think though what are
your thoughts on all of this stuff the
spoilers are finally coming out so let's
have some fun and do some speculating
put your thoughts and questions down
below I want to thank everyone for
supporting the channel by continuing to
watch my videos I really do appreciate
that I hope you all have a great day I
will see you in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]